>> Judge Jeanine: BLACK LIVES
MATTER MAKING SYMPATHETIC
EXCUSES AFTER THEIR SHADY
FINANCES GOT EXPOSED.
THE RADICAL GROUP TAKING A
TWITTER AND APOLOGIZING FOR THE
DISTRESSED CAUSED BY
INFLAMMATORY REPORTS ABOUT THEIR
USE OF DONATIONS TO BUY A SWANKY
$6 MILLION CALIFORNIA MANSION.
THEY CLAIM THE HOME WAS BOUGHT
TO PROVIDE A SAFE SPACE FOR
BLACK CREATIVITY.
BUT HAS ALLEGEDLY TRIED TO HIDE
THE WHOLE EXISTENCE.
I'M GOING TO COME TO YOU FIRST,
GREG.
WHAT I FIND MOST INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS IS THAT THE HOME WAS
PURCHASED FOR $3.1 MILLION.
A FEW DAYS LATER BLACK LIVES
MATTER BOUGHT IT FOR
$5.8 MILLION IN CASH.
THAT'S AN INCREASE OF
2.7 MILLION.
>> Jesse: WHO WAS THE BROKER?
>> Judge Jeanine: FORGET THE
BROKER.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHO GETS THE
CASH!
>> Judge Jeanine: WHO BOUGHT
IT FOR 3.1 AND THEN FLIPPED IT?
>> Greg: YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO CALL TIDE.
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF LAUNDRY.
THE WORST PART IS THE LANGUAGE.
THIS IS A TIME FOR HEALING.
WHENEVER SIMPLY DOES SOMETHING
WRONG NOW, THEY GO YOU KNOW WE
NEED?
WE NEED TIME TO HEAL AFTER THIS.
WAS THE CLOSING MEETING WHEN YOU
BOUGHT THE PLACE THAT TRAUMATIC?
SIGNING ALL THOSE PAPERS?
I BET THEY PAID CASH.
COULDN'T OF BEEN THAT TRAUMATIC.
I'M ACTUALLY JEALOUS.
>> Jesse: IF DAD PRESSES
TRAUMATIC.
I NEED TO BE IN AN INSTITUTION.
IF BAD PRESS IS TRAUMATIC.
IF THIS IS A MENTION FOR BLACK
CREATIVE PEOPLE, DO THEY NEED
THE POOL, DO THEY NEED THE SWING
POOL?
>> Judge Jeanine: PART OF
THEIR CREATIVITY AND JOY.
>> Jesse: PHOTOS.
COME ON.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WAS GOING
TO DANA.
>> Greg: CORPORATE OFFICES.
>> Jesse: WHAT ELSE?
DO YOU NEED A FIRE PIT?
>> Judge Jeanine: HAROLD.
HAROLD AND I ARE PASSING
LEGISLATION WE BOTH AGREE ON.
THE ORGANIZATION USING DEFEND.
2 MILLION TO COVERT RELIEF.
25 MILLION TO BLACK LIVES
ORGANIZATION AND THEY SEE IF YOU
QUESTION THEM YOU ARE RACIST FOR
QUESTIONING THEM.
>> Harold: IN MY MIND, THE
CONDUCT HERE IN THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
AN AWFUL DISPARITY.
BLACK LIVES DO MATTER BUT THIS
CONDUCT IS INDEFENSIBLE.
WHOEVER IS RESPONSIBLE, I HOPE
THE ORGANIZATION, IF THERE'S
MALFEASANCE AND IF THERE'S
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY I HOPE THEY
HOLD THAT PERSON ACCOUNTABLE AND
GET THE NAME BACK AND TRY TO DO
GOOD THINGS.
>> Judge Jeanine: DANA, HAROLD
IS TALKING ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE MOVEMENT AND THE
ORGANIZATION.
THE ORGANIZATION DESERVES TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
>> Dana: I AGR